en tirant une conclusion différente du
membre du CCN ont souhaité publier une
réserve considérant ce site
que franchir
ce pas législatif sans ces efforts
préalables représentaient un
représenterait un risque de renoncement
que nous ne souhaitons pas prendre le 13
septembre dernier le président de la
République a annoncé le lancement d'une
convention citoyenne sur la fin de vie
dans le pilotage a été confié au Conseil
économique social et environnemental et
que la première ministre a saisi de
l'interrogation suivante le cadre
d'accompagnement de la fin de vie est-il
adapté aux différentes situations
rencontrées ou d'éventuelles changements
devraient être introduit les conclusions
de la convention sont attendues pour la
fin mars 2023 dans cette attente
messieurs pourriez-vous nous exposer
quel serait cette voie pour une
application éthique de l'aide actif à
mourir et en quoi le cadre législatif
actuel devrait être modifié le cas
échéant pour ouvrir cette voie monsieur
le président
c'est la parole
merci madame la Présidente merci
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
c'est l'actrice
donc je vous voyiez aujourd'hui comme
président du CCNE et oublions que vous
m'avez interpellé à plusieurs reprises
dans le cadre du covid
alors
peut-être un rappel sur et je laisserai
la parole ensuite aux deux rapporteurs
sur les conditions dans lequel a été
construit la vie 139
je rappelle son titre parce qu'il est
important question éthique
relative aux situations de la fin de vie
autonomie et solidarité
en juin 2021 alors qu'on était encore en
situation de de sinon de crise sanitaire
en tout cas de
la question se posait encore j'ai
souhaité que le CCNE s'auto saisis de ce
sujet compte tenu d'un certain nombre de
démarches parlementaires que nous avions
vu dans le premier semestre 2021 pour
éventuellement aller vers une
modification de la loi-classe et Unity
et il m'a pas assez important que le
CCNE s'auto saisissent de ce sujet
indépendamment d'une commande qui aurait
pu être une commande politique
il y a donc eu comme la construction de
ce font les avis du CCNE avec un groupe
de travail les trois rapporteurs qui a
commencé à travailler des l'été qui a
auditionné
plus de 40 personnes ou groupes
représentations
et ensuite on s'est trouvé à la fin de
l'année 2021 avec une situation pas
inédite mais voilà qui est tombé au
milieu de la vie avec un changement des
membres du CCNE d'une partie des membres
du CCNE et donc on avait déjà commencé à
travailler la ville le groupe de travail
avait déjà présenté ses premières
visions sa première vision au CCN
plénier puisque je vous rappelle que
dans la fonctionnement de notre instance
toutes les décisions sont prises au
niveau du CCNE plaignait même si elles
sont guidées par les recommandations
d'un groupe de travail
et donc voilà il y a eu du retard comme
souvent dans les dans les nominations
dans ces dans ces instances et donc nous
avons continué à travailler puis le
nouveau comité est arrivé évidemment on
est reparti de zéro pas mais il a fallu
qu'ils s'en partent entre guillemets du
sujet donc il s'est emparé du sujet le
groupe de travail à ce moment-là c'est
passé directement sur le mode du travail
du plénier complet et cet avis a été
voté à une très large majorité fin juin
à ce moment là depuis le début et c'est
normal sur un sujet de ce type
il est il existait une partie des
membres du groupe de travail et certains
également au niveau du comité plénier
qui avait qui portait un avis nuancé
minoritaire sur les recommandations qui
peuvent être faites et c'est très simple
c'est très très simple que sur un sujet
aussi difficile aussi complexe et c'est
le propre même du CCNE nous puissions
avoir des avis minoritaires le groupe
minoritaire a souhaité fin juin au
moment où nous avons voté cet avis
reréfléchir sur les conditions dans
lequel
il souhaitait présenter son avis
minoritaire c'est la raison pour
laquelle je n'ai pas présenté cet avis
de façon publique début juillet comme je
l'avais prévu mais j'ai attendu que le
groupe minoritaire me redonne le texte
qui lui convenait sous le forme d'une
réserve entre guillemets
qui m'a été donné dans le courant du
mois d'août et nous avons rediscuté lors
du premier planning de septembre et
finalement cet avis a donc été rendu en
tenant compte et en incluant dans la vie
cette cette réserve pour le début
septembre si je passe un peu de temps
sur ce qui est très chronologique et qui
ne peut le fond de la vie c'est pour que
les choses soient claires pour tout le
monde qui ne le CCNE est une instance
d'intelligence collective c'est une
instance qui doit tenir compte surtout
sur des sujets difficiles de ce type
d'avis choix minoritaire soit soit
différent c'est ce que nous avons fait
sur le fond la très large majorité du
CCNE a voté cet avis et la réserve et a
été votée par huit membres sur les 45
membres actuels du CCN donc voilà sur
sur les sur les points alors ensuite sur
la ville lui-même
[Musique]
et c'est là où en effet on a posé un
certain nombre de situations en
particulier pour des personnes pour des
patients et atteints de maladies
chroniques dégénératives
neurodégénératives en particulier ou
atteints de maladies incurables mais non
pas à court terme puisque la loi-classe
néonetti permet de résoudre des
problèmes à court terme mais dans le
moyen terme ce qu'on appelait dans le
moyen terme c'est quelques semaines à
quelques mois et là où un certain nombre
de situations où la loi classique ne
répond pas totalement la question et là
en effet on va vous préciser dans
quelles conditions éthique une porte
pourrait être entrebâillé sur une vision
nouvelle de ce qui pourrait être une
aide à une mort dans la dignité et puis
enfin dans la troisième partie et elle
est à mes yeux aussi très importante
parce que c'est le rôle du CCNE d'être
garant que
sur un sujet aussi difficile
sur un sujet où on voit bien on touche
au fond même de l'humanité on touche sur
des questions
individuelles très fortes très sensible
et bien on puisse laisser s'exprimer
bien sûr
ce qui sera peut-être un vote des
parlementaires et des sénateurs mais
qu'avant cette période il puisse y avoir
un grand débat national qui puisse
s'ouvrir sur ce sujet et on a maintenant
et on sait on a on sait mieux mené en
France ce type de grand débat national
donc on a recommandé en effet le
président de la République dans son
communiqué nous a suivi ces trois
parties du débat national qui vont
porter à la fois sur ce que va porter le
CESU avec finalement une convention
citoyenne ce qui sera porté par le CCNE
et les espaces éthiques régionaux dans
les territoires comme on l'avait fait
lors des états généraux de la bioéthique
avec des réunions d'information pour les
citoyens qui
perdu dans le terminologie dans un
certain nombre de questions et qui
pourront a juste titre poser des
questions à des experts dans un climat
de neutralité même s'il y aura du débat
on en a bien compte on se rend bien
compte et puis une troisième partie qui
sera menée plutôt par le Centre national
de fin de soins palliatifs et de fin de
vie sur ce problème très difficile de
comment finalement on a médicalisé la
mort dans ce pays depuis de nombreuses
années 90% des décès surviennent à
l'hôpital c'est une fonction qui n'était
pas forcément celle des médecins bien
sûr de s'occuper des patients les plus
fragiles mais s'occuper de l'ensemble je
dirais de la mortalité c'est une vraie
question pour pour un médecin et donc
d'écouter des équipes soignantes soit
spécialisées dans les soins palliatifs
soit non spécialisé mais qui a
différents titres sont impliqués on voit
bien là les cancérologues on voit là les
certains certains services de neurologie
certains services de réanimation et
cette prise en compte je dirais de
l'ensemble des équipes soignantes et pas
seulement des médecins parce que sur la
fin de vie les aides-soignantes ont
autant d'importance largement qu'un
médecin et bien sur ces points là il est
essentiel d'écouter les équipes même si
elles partent plutôt actuellement avec
un regard plutôt critique entre
guillemets sur le sujet mais ça pose
finalement la question essentielle et je
terminerai là-dessus est-ce que notre
mort nous appartient ou est-ce qu'elle
appartient à la société qui la délégué
au médecin et cette question
fondamentale au plan éthique est mise
maintenant sur la table
très bien alors messieurs les
rapporteurs qui commencent
le président
mesdames messieurs sénateurs je suis
heureux de me retrouver au Sénat dans
une autre vie
lorsqu'il y a eu à discuter de cette loi
de 2016 j'étais venu au Sénat en
débattre les gens gardent j'en garde un
très bon souvenir et en plus lors de la
commission mixte paritaire non s'il a
pas dû trouver entre les deux assemblées
un accord
avec Régis et sous la présidence de
Jean-François d'être précis nous avons
travaillé avec un groupe de travail ce
sujet et je commencerai par les mots de
conclusion de président
ce qu'il disait pose le sujet d'un
équilibre entre
solidarité
de la société vis-à-vis de ses citoyens
et l'autonomie de la personne
alors pourquoi nous avons décidé de nous
auto saisir
il y a un an et demi
peut-être pour trois raisons
la première raison
il y avait un débat fort
dans l'opinion sur ce sujet je ne parle
pas des sondages si pour moi n'ont pas
grande importance sur un quel sujet
il y a eu des initiatives parlementaires
et puis il y a eu un contexte
aussi important
la situation
des soignants dans les hôpitaux
dans les structures
médico-sociales des EHPAD
où il y avait un mal-être et le message
qui était passé était
résumé nous avons pas les moyens pas
forcément financiers mais les moyens de
prendre en charge correctement les
patients et puis il y a eu cette période
du covid
vous êtes des élus vous savez les drames
qui se sont passés
dans les EHPAD non pas
du fait de l'épidémie même parce que les
mesures étaient prises mais toutes les
conséquences
auprès des familles auprès des personnes
des pavillons pas pu faire leur deuil
bref un climat extrêmement je crois
qu'on ne peut pas aborder ce sujet sans
avoir tout cela dans la tête c'est ce
qu'on a essayé moi je sais que en tant
que sénatrice et sénateurs vous avez à
travers vos territoires tout cela en
tête
et puis
il sait pas rien passé depuis 20 ans
depuis 20 ans
le Sénat et l'Assemblée les
parlementaires
ont toujours travaillé
pour tenir les deux bouts de la chaîne
solidarité autonomique solidarité avec
les lois de 1999 sur des soins
palliatifs
je fais une parenthèse mais à titre
individuelle j'espère que le président
Me fâchera pas je crois qu'il fera
changer de nom un jour
faudra peut-être plus parler de soin
d'accompagnement parce que soin
palliatifs c'est quand il y a plus rien
à faire c'est ressenti comme ça comme le
rappeler le président et c'est pas des
petites choses dans beaucoup d'hôpitaux
c'est ailleurs
je crois que tes soins d'accompagnement
c'est des soins c'est véritablement
l'institution dans notre pays d'une
politique de santé de la personne
de la personne et on développe ce sujet
sur lequel lequel régisse va venir donc
99 c'était quand même de la part de la
nation une volonté de solidarité il y a
eu 2002 la loi couchter
la loi Kouchner qui
renforce j'allais dire le pouvoir des
patients pouvoir arrêter un traitement
c'est pas rien
prêt bien sûr un débat avec l'équipe
soignante il y a eu la loi de Jean
Léonetti en 2005 qui était l'obstination
des raisonnables
j'attire votre attention
c'est un sujet qui va revenir
d'actualité dans les jours qui viennent
je crois que c'est autour du vin 20
octobre à novembre il y a une QPC aux
conseils constitutionnel
où ce sujet va être traité je sais pas
si vous avez suivi cela d'un côté des
médecins l'équipe soignante qui
considèrent que prolonger la vie à la
personne et une obstination
déraisonnable et de l'autre la famille
ou une partie de la famille qui
considère que à travers des directives
anticipées ce qu'il faut vérifier la
personne quel que soit la situation ne
souhaitait pas interruption de la vie
donc c'est
à dire la confrontation de jaillir de
loi de droit et donc c'est un plus
important et enfin la loi de 2016 auquel
j'ai pu participer et aux quelques
années au Sénat amender et adopté c'est
trois nouveaux
droitsables la personne de confiance et
la sédation profonde et continue
jusqu'au décès donc on voit bien à
travers ce Corps législatif qui est un
cadre il y a cet équilibre entre
solidarité et autonomie
et je crois que les trois questions
auxquelles nous aurions nous ont eu à
répondre
sont relativement simple
première question c'est
est-ce que ces lois sont correctement
appliquées sur l'ensemble du territoire
est-ce qu'il y a des inégalités
territoriales ou sociales
ton application de ces lois
nous répondons clairement oui
des soins palliatifs vous allez faire un
rapport le Sénat un rapport très très
fouillé voilà on en mesure que ça soit
les limites géographiques
certains départements ne disposent pas
de soins palliatifs on en mesure en
terme de formation de recherche
et de nombre de paysph en soins
palliatifs je crois que à ma
connaissance il y a pas un laboratoire
une cerne
sur la recherche palliatifs et il existe
pas je crois de paysph actuellement dans
le pays sur ces soins là donc on voit
bien qu'il y a cette inégalité et puis
je parlais accompagnement pour
substituer ce mot sur un type il y a
c'est aussi volonté de des familles de
mobilité c'est à dire ne pas terminer sa
vie à l'hôpital et c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui quand on regarde la
situation dans les EHPAD ou à domicile
il y a beaucoup de retard sur les soins
palliatifs c'est la première chose la
première question à laquelle on devait
s'interroger et la deuxième question
c'est sur la loi 2016 il y a pas
d'évaluation il y a pas d'évaluation de
cette loi mais moi je vous suis le site
qu'un exemple le CHU de Poitiers que je
connais un peu moins mal la directrice
générale a recruté une infirmière qui
est passée par la en cancérologie soit
palliatif ou
et EHPAD pour populariser ce que sont
les directives anticipées
populariser auprès des patients mais
aussi auprès du corps auprès du corps
médical sera sédation profonde et
continue
là encore il y a il y a des des
insuffisances ou parfois des
méconnaissance
puis l'autre question
qui donc sur les la loi de 2016 je sais
pas ce qui a décidé de Sénat je crois
savoir que l'assemblée a décidé d'une
évaluation
voilà bon ça c'est au Parlement c'est à
vous de voir quels seront les
évaluations
qui sont et la troisième question
qui ne doit pas être dissocié des deux
autres j'y insiste réduire
la vie du CCNE à l'aide activa mourir ça
serait un contre sens et je pense que ce
serait quelque chose qui pourrait
fausser totalement le débat
la question on a voulu se poser est-ce
qu'il y a des situations
particulières exceptionnelles ou y
compris la loi de 2016 ne répond pas
et où on peut
légitimement s'interroger y compris dans
des situations les sons palliatifs sont
présents là on touche au cœur de
comment dans une
un lieu où la solidarité joue
l'autonomie peut exister parce que nous
on pense et je parle de contrôle de
Régis et de Jean-François
il ne peut pas y avoir d'autonomie sans
solidarité
car si
on considère cela ça veut dire que notre
société
décide de laisser aux personnes
seules la prise en compte de la mort une
société qui fonctionne comme ça et à mon
sens
inacceptable pour les uns et les autres
et donc le sujet de l'autonomie
à essayer on l'aborder
non pas en demande en réforme mais on
s'est dit la question que l'on s'est
posée s'il législateur
décidait d'aller dans cette direction
comment devons-nous aborder ce sujet
est-ce qu'il est éthique de l'aborder
par rapport au CCSE par rapport aux avis
que le cessionnaire avait formulé
précédemment et deuxièmement
quel cadre
il est nécessaire de mettre en place
pour
encadrer cet éventuel
c'est éventuel avancée voilà le travail
que nous avons fait et je reviens pas
sur la dernière partie de des
recommandations
c'est pas notre rôle de dire qu'un
référendum n'est pas adapté à un tel
sujet mais nous l'avons dit quand même
ce que je crois que la situation est
tellement complexe que c'est vraiment la
démocratie représentative d'aborder ce
sujet après une conférence citoyenne
mais Régis va détailler des mesures sur
lesquelles nous avons travaillé merci
merci Monsieur Aubry
merci madame la Présidente merci
mesdames messieurs d'être attentif à ces
questions
complexes comme toujours quand on parle
de questions de fin de vie ce n'est
jamais simple ce qui rend les choses
compliquées c'est qu'on aucun d'entre
nous ne peut avoir l'expérience de la
fin de vie personne n'en est revenu
donc on est forcément en questionnement
par rapport à quelque chose dont on ne
peut pas avoir d'expérience et les
expériences dont on se souvient sont en
général pas des expériences très
qui laisse des souvenirs autre que
douloureux l'expérience de proche qui
pourquoi il est difficile à mon avis de
débattre est-ce que nous avons essayé de
faire pendant plus d'un an au sein du
CCNE c'est de prendre un peu de distance
par rapport à nos propres expériences de
nature personnelle
je parvenir sur ce qui a été dit parce
que
je pense qu'il faut qu'on laisse une
large place à vos questions mais je
voudrais peut-être pointer de 3
spécificités qui ont motivé quand même
notre
auto saisine je parle aussi alors
évidemment en tant que membre du comité
consultatif mais je suis aussi médecin
professeur de médecine palliative
engagée depuis dans ce domaine depuis
assez longtemps
moi j'avoue que je trouve que nous ne
pouvons pas et nous ne devons pas
ignorer un changement de paradigme très
conséquent dans le champ de la médecine
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus qu'hier on est confronté à
des situations impensées de fin de vie
et c'est un pensée c'est parfois la
médecine qui le génère
c'est le corollaire du progrès
de la médecine dont on va pas discuter
heureusement d'ailleurs sauf à être
révisionniste à mon sens mais le corps à
l'air du progrès
et y compris malgré le développement
dont on redira qu'il est insuffisant et
je reviendrai brièvement mais le
corollaire de ce progrès c'est que
aujourd'hui nous sommes confrontés à des
situations que Jean-François Delfraissy
nommé
de personnes qui sont confrontées à des
maladies chronicisées
avec une incurabilité de leur maladie
donc c'est comme si on avait un peu
allongé le temps de la fin de
l'existence et de la confrontation avec
la question de sa propre finitude
ça touche tous les âges
on a une transformation de certains
cancers en maladie chronique par exemple
on est en train de d'augmenter
l'espérance de vie de certaines maladies
neurodégénératives
mais une conséquence aussi qu'on voit
régulièrement c'est elle est liée au
vieillissement qui lui-même est lié à
ses avancées techniques et scientifiques
on a le plus en plus de personnes qui
vivent de plus en plus longtemps avec
quelque chose qui était une forme
d'impensée une polie pathologiste ils
sont plus atteintes plusieurs maladies
synchrones
et les questions qu'on doit se poser
elles sont de deux ordres
ou 3 ans
le premier ordre de question c'est
comment faire pour que la médecine ne
fabrique pas des situations
insensées elle le peut nous le disons
dans cet avis nous l'avions dit dans un
avis précédent
ça n'est pas parce que l'on sait faire
que l'on doit faire en médecine qu'en
faire conduire faire souffrir
le deuxième axe qu'il faut aborder pour
essayer de
d'éclairer ces questions là c'est se
dire est-ce que les différents plans de
développement des soins palliatifs dont
un est encore en cours
suffisent ou pas et ce sur quoi nous
insistons beaucoup dans cet avis je vais
pas revenir sur ce qu'a dit
Jean-François delfresci mais j'assis sur
une notion qui est la nécessité
aujourd'hui compte tenu de ce que je
viens de vous dire de développer et
d'avoir pour tous les professionnels de
santé une culture palliative intégrée à
leur pratique professionnelle ça
apparaît extrêmement important de mon
point de vue ça appelle
la nécessité d'actionner un levier c'est
celui de la formation et celui de la
recherche
et ces deux leviers sont insuffisamment
mobiliser aujourd'hui on ne forme pas
les gens suffisamment à la question de
la réflexion sur la finitude de l'homme
les humanités médicales ont en partie
disparue on ne forme pas assez les
personnes à la réflexion éthique est une
réflexion compliquée
interprofessionnelle qui nécessite
d'apprendre à débattre
à ne pas être sûr de soi ou pas trop sûr
de soi
mais il n'en reste pas moins vrai que au
terme de cette réflexion et quand bien
même nous aurions un développement de la
culture paliative intégrée aux soins
palliatifs avec une universitarisation
effective
de ces questions un développement de la
recherche il n'en reste pas moins vrai
que nous sommes et nous serons
confrontés à des situations alors qu'on
peut qualifier de rares ou
d'exceptionnel mais de personnes qui
avant la toute fin de leur vie donc
avant le champ dans lequel s'applique la
loi actuelle laisse Leonetti je parle en
particulier de la question de
l'acierdation profonde et continue on
est confronté à des personnes qui
dont l'existence
n'est plus que souffrance
ce sont des personnes qui font des
demandes d'aide actives à mourir ce sont
des personnes celles dont nous parlons
là qui bien entendu doivent avoir
bénéficié de soins palliatifs enfin on
imagine mal que ça soit optionnel
et nous avons beaucoup réfléchi à cette
notion d'être de active à mourir et on
distingue je me permets d'insister parce
que la nuance est majeure pour nous on
distingue dans ses aides actives à
mourir on distingue bien la question de
l'assistance au suicide de celle de
l'euthanasie
peut-être pour
l'assistance au suicide consiste à
permettre une personne d'avoir accès à
un produit létal qu'elle se délivre ou
qu'elle absorbe elle-même
j'attire votre attention que
dans certains états des États-Unis comme
l'État d'Oregon que nous avons
particulièrement regardé
on voit bien qu'un nombre important de
personnes qui ont demandé l'aide
d'active à mourir et donc l'accès à
l'assistance au suicide ne vont pas
chercher le produit létal et parmi
celles qui vont le chercher ce produit
l'état d'un certain nombre ne
l'absorbent pas ça n'est pas parce que
on fait une demande que l'on va au bout
de cette demande à la différence de
l'euthanasie ou finalement si vous
répondez à la demande par un acte qui
est administré l'administration d'un
produit vital par un tiers c'est
évidemment son retour vous voyez cette
nuance elle est de notre point de vue
fondamental en ce sens que pour
reprendre ce que disait à la classe nous
essayons de travailler sur
cette notion de respect de l'autonomie
de la personne tout autant que sur ce
devoir de solidarité que nous avons
vis-à-vis des personnes en situation de
grande souffrance et de grandes
vulnérabilité nous insistons beaucoup
dans cet avis en plus sur le fait alors
là-dessus à la lumière de quelques
travaux de recherche qui viennent d'être
publiés et nous avons auditionné les
chercheurs ou les équipes de recherche
qui ont travaillé là-dessus nous
insistons beaucoup sur
le fait qu'une demande ne signifie pas
une volonté
une demande avant qu'elle ne soit
l'expression de la volonté doit être
tout à fait analysée il y a beaucoup de
demandes qui traduisent autre chose que
la volonté de mourir mais l'épuisement
de la vie les plus la souffrance etc
donc c'est c'est demande doit faire
l'objet d'une analyse on imagine mal
quand bien même la loi évoluerait que
l'on accepte comme ça parce que c'est
demandé à
la possibilité de
l'assistance au suicide il faut que
cette analyse soit fine il faut que la
demande soit réitérer qu'elle soit ferme
et que la demande et la volonté soit
confirmée par un collectif et pas
simplement par une personne
donc nous en sommes arrivés à faire
cette distinction qui peut apparaître
spécieuse certains mais qui ne nous
apparaissent surtout pas entre de formes
d'aide active à Maurice l'assistance au
suicide et la question de l'euthanasie
pour les raisons que je viens de vous
développer auquel on peut naturellement
répondre
si vous vous interrogez sur ce point
c'est le segment sur lequel nous pensons
qu'effectivement il pourrait
être éthique de faire évoluer le droit
dans cette direction il nous semble
qu'il pourrait y avoir pour répondre
par solidarité et par respect de
l'autonomie de la personne à certaines
situations qui donnent mon point de vue
et de mon expérience il se trouve que je
travaille sur ces situations en tant que
chercheur sont très très rares si on y
fait bien attention mais la rareté ne
doit pas nous empêcher de réfléchir à
cette réalité
donc nous sommes arrivés à
cette idée qui nous faut
à la fois imaginer un développement
d'une politique d'accompagnement des
vulnérabilités que ce soit le
vieillissement ou les soins pallatifs
qui soient à la hauteur des réalités que
nous connaissons des besoins qui ne sont
pas couverts en matière de culture
palliative
et c'est ce qui nous différencie
d'ailleurs du huit personnes qui ont
souhaité qu'il y a une alerte nous
pensons majoritairement que c'est et
nous ne pouvons pas conditionner
conditionner la réflexion sur une
évolution du droit à au développement
qui serait évalué des soins palliatifs
bien sûr que nous le demandons il y
aurait rien de pire qu'une loi
qui ne s'accompagnerait pas d'une
politique d'une loi autorisant
l'aide active à mourir et si de notre
point de vue plutôt la question de
l'assistance au suicide et qui ne serait
pas accompagné d'une vraie politique
d'accompagnement des situations de
vulnérabilité ça serait à mon avis un
peu catastrophique
et puis Jean-François delfred il a dit
et je termine là-dessus ce qui nous
apparaît important c'est que
ces nuances dont nous essayons de vous
parler toutes ces
toutes ces nuances nous apparaissent
essentielles à connaître de tous nous
avons une phaseuse tendance à vouloir
simplifier ce qui est complexe et en
l'occurrence je prends qu'il ne faut le
faut pas et donc c'est un peu sur ce
point que nous insistons sur l'intérêt
du débat public parce qu'à mon avis ces
questions cette complexité elle doit
être explicite ça nous apparaît
fondamental et c'est sur cette base
d'une complexité assumée de nuances qui
apparaissent comme essentiel que nous
pouvons de notre point de vue envisager
une évolution éthique autour à la fois
des politiques et du droit
merci merci beaucoup donc plusieurs
collègues inscrits Corinne Imbert qui
avait été co-rapporteur de la mission
sur les siens palliatifs merci mais la
présidente merci monsieur le Président
merci chers collègue pour vos propos et
la présentation de ce cet avis
[Musique]
sur tout d'abord monsieur le Président
vous l'avez rappelé sur le bilan de la
loi classe Leonetti c'est un bilan
partagé avec le Sénat et notamment avec
ce qui est exprimé dans dans le rapport
de la mission d'information sur les
soins palliatifs que j'avais eu
l'honneur de conduire avec mes deux
collègues christine bofortidosa et
Michel meunier qui sont ici présentes
néanmoins 6 ans seulement j'allais dire
alors le temps il court le temps est
long tout est relatif évidemment
notamment quand on parle de fin de vie
mais six ans se sont écoulées depuis la
dernière intervention du législateur
donc depuis 2016 la situation a-t-elle à
ce point changé que le Comité
consultatif national des ticket
en 2013 qui n'était pas souhaitable de
lui de légaliser l'assistance au speed
puisse juger possible de légiférer à
présent dans ce sens et la vie estime en
effet qu'il existe une voix pour une
application éthique de la dactive à
mourir selon les termes employés et
le rapport si des phénomènes assez
hétérogènes pour justifier l'existence
de cette voie en faisant référence à tes
éléments objectifs et c'est ce que le
professeur régisse
évoqué tout à l'heure c'est à dire les
situations limites que constitue une
nouvelle forme de soin avec la
médiathèque médicalisation et donc cet
allongement de la fin de vie et puis des
éléments subjectifs notamment
l'extension de situation de solitude une
demande croissante d'autonomie psychique
etc
et ce que je voudrais savoir si peut-on
quantifier ou circonscire plus
précisément les situations objectives
le sujet ne revêtit-il pas au fond une
démission une dimension plus subjective
comme objectif dans le sens où il
procède moins de la prise en compte de
la situation des personnes qui vont
mourir que de celles qui veulent mourir
moins de la fin de vie apprement dit que
que du suicide
l'un des arguments les plus persuasifs
pour légiférant en matière d'être active
à mourir serais-je mais bien le
conditionnel serait celui selon lequel
il s'agit d'une demande claire de la
société et vous l'avez évoqué je pense
qu'il faudrait exactement savoir l'état
de l'opinion en la matière et d'où
l'importance d'une consultation parce
qu'on voit bien que certains sondages un
petit peu plus subtils font à part est
une préférence pour les soins palliatifs
plutôt que pour l'aide active à mourir
et plutôt que l'euthanasie mais on parle
bien ici vous avez bien fait de le
rappeler sur de l'aide active à mourir
et vous le savez encore mieux que moi ou
en tout cas au moins autant
la volonté des individus peut changer or
quand la loi est votée la loi est votée
pour tous donc et souvent la volonté des
individus qui peut changer les
professionnels de santé nous le disent
on l'a entendu quand on a conduit cette
mission des personnes qui arrivent dans
une structure de palliatifs qui voulait
mourir et puis qu'une fois qu'ils sont
accompagnés
et très importante effectivement et bien
veulent un peu plus de temps à vivre
donc c'est pour ça que tout ça est
important
de questions remarques ne doit pas ne
doit-on pas craindre que la modification
de la loi pour autoriser l'aide à qui va
mourir ne servent de prétexte pour ne
pas développer les soins palliatifs
donc tout s'accorde à reconnaître
l'insuffisance sur notre territoire et
c'est ce que nous avions pointé
également évidemment et je crois que
vous le partagez dans notre rapport et
enfin une une dernière question que
pensez-vous de l'évolution de
l'expression mourir dans la dignité à
laquelle certains préfèrent aujourd'hui
l'expression mourir dans la liberté je
vous remercie
peut-être prendre des vous les réponds
maintenant il y a encore de collègues on
va prendre toutes les questions voilà
Bernard Chaumier ensuite Olivier Hainaut
merci
madame la Présidente merci à vous trois
pour votre vos exposés au
moi quand je lis votre rapport j'étais
perplexe je vous posez quelques
questions et j'ai trouvé vos
explications orales plus convaincantes
en fait ce qui montre bien la difficulté
de parler du sujet c'est à dire que il
fait quand même
80 pages je sais plus donc beaucoup de
choses à écrire 63 pardon mais en je
trouve que les choses ont été mieux
exprimées oralement par vous-même et
avec cette question quand même
fondamentale puisque c'est un rapport du
CCNE c'est pas un rapport politique
cette question du principe d'autonomie
qu'on a vu croître au fil des lois de
bioéthiques c'est un principe c'est une
valeur qui a grandi qui a de plus en
plus infusé
nos lois de bioéthiques et là on se pose
la question de la limite de ce principe
que Jean-François delfrecy illustré
parfaitement la fin de son propos en
disant la question c'est est-ce que ma
mort m'appartient donc c'est une
question je crois qui nous interroge
tous et moi à laquelle je trouve la
réponse très difficile à apporter parce
que certes ce principe a pris une place
centrale et qui faut lui reconnaissent
et c'est une demande de la société mais
il ne peut pas ne pas être confronté au
principe d'intérêt général et pas
uniquement au principe de solidarité
d'ailleurs il doit être confronté à
d'autres principes que le principe de
solidarité donc ça c'est une première
question alors évidemment vous n'êtes
pas allé au bout dans votre rapport mais
pour pour le législateur je crois que on
ne peut pas trancher cette question
d'une nouvelle loi si on ne tranche pas
notre rapport les limites composent au
principe d'autonomie deuxièmement vous
posez dans votre recommandation à la fin
de votre apport vous avez des termes
très forts vous posez des conditions
strictes auxquelles il serait
inacceptable de transiger en cas de
législation sur l'aide active à mourir
c'est-à-dire en termes de langage que
tout le monde comprend des lignes rouges
et quand au niveau de ligne rouge c'est
à peu près c'est essentiellement sur un
réel accès aux soins palliatifs aux
soins mais bon d'accompagnement pour
l'ensemble des Français très bien qui
croit au cours de cette table que à
échéance de deux ans trois ans ou 5 ans
vous avez rappelé monsieur Aubry les
problèmes de forme et qui sont de
formation notamment tous les Français
auront accès à ces soins moi je crois
pas un mot je suis pas là depuis très
longtemps 5 ans mais je veux dire les
les plans sont un palliatifs on les
enchaîne les assurances ministérielles
on en fait des colliers entiers et une
réalité c'est que la situation elle
évolue je dis pas mais franchement un
rythme qui nous met très très loin
l'objectif donc moi j'ai lu votre avis
en bossien comme
à l'inverse de ce qui en est sorti dans
les bas publics c'est le CCN ouvre la
porte à une législation sur l'aide
active à mourir et que moi quand je lis
votre rapport je lis c'est pas pour
demain donc dites-moi ce que vous avez
voulu nous dire très très exactement et
puis juste de remarques 1 je pense qu'on
est j'y faire pas en la matière avec
l'expérience personnelle et je pense que
c'est un biais qu'il faut absolument
éviter j'ai je dis à mes collègues
j'étais très déçu par le dernier examen
de la proposition de loi qu'on aille au
Sénat notre collègue Marie-Pierre la
Gontrie que mes collègues de mon groupe
politique ont tous voté moi je me suis
abstenu
parce que je trouve que le débat était
beaucoup trop justement porté sur des
expériences personnelles par contre
répondez pas une question fondamentale
et je l'ai dit à Marie-Pierre
à la question fondamentale pour moi car
rappelé Régis Aubry qui est
le suicide assisté versus le thanazi
parce que ça pose la question une
question fondamentale c'est le rôle des
soignants
qu'est-ce qu'on accepte que les
soignants fassent
voilà est-ce qu'on accepte que d'une
façon ou d'une autre les soignants
participent directement
à un processus d'administration de la
mort et cette interrogation à la
traversée les mouvements de défense de
droits de l'homme depuis des décennies
dans dans ce qui était dans d'autres
pays voilà
l'implication des soignants dans des
process liés à la mort et ça
indépendamment du principe d'autonomie
veut dire toute société fonctionne par
une répartition des rôles et par des
délimitations qui sont compréhensibles
par chacun
au nom du principe d'automonomie faire
qu'un citoyen puisse accéder au suicide
assisté est une question faire en sorte
donner à des soignants le droit ou la
possibilité de participer à ces
processus c'est une autre question et
une loi qui ne porte pas cette
différence là c'est une mauvaise loi qui
sera inapplicable
peut-être te passer à ces questions pour
compléter ce que dit Bernard Chaumier
l'ordre des médecins et concernés si on
parle de la place des soignants entre
autres le médecin travaille sur le sujet
et on les entendra en commission puisque
le président de l'Ordre m'a dit qu'il
rendrait un avis plutôt début novembre
après avoir consulté l'ensemble des
conseils départementaux de l'ordre de
l'ordre des médecins
on va peut-être déjà répondre à ces
questions ensuite nous aurons deux
autres sénateurs qui se sont inscrits
qui commencent
facteur objectif ou subjectif j'allais
dire des deux
sur les facteurs objectifs et moi je
tiens à le dire
la loi de 2016
ne couvre pas tous les sujets
que nous abordons que nous abordons dans
cette avis mais que nous avions abordé
et Régis a joué un rôle dans le
précédent à vie
on avait abordé à travers la situation
exceptionnelle c'est vrai que dans le
précédent avis le CCNE ne demandez pas
de légiférer mais avait posé ce sujet de
situation exceptionnelle
alors il y a un facteur objectif facteur
objectif c'est que la sédation profonde
à court terme
ne fonctionne pas médicalement lorsque
le pronostic vital n'est pas engagé à
court terme mais à moyen terme
c'est un sujet je crois qu'il faut qu'on
se le dise là mais les médecins qui sont
autour de de cette table le savent le
sable donc il y a véritablement sous
réserve que les soins d'accompagnement
existent il peut y avoir des situations
il peut y avoir des situations où
la question se pose même si la
solidarité existe et c'est dans ce cas
là dans ce cadre là que nous avons
abordé l'aide à mourir alors
je suis pas si on a été meilleur à
l'oral où elle est fumée
quand j'entends ça ça m'inquiète
toujours
je sais pas si on n'avait pas été assez
précis à l'écrit et on a complété à
l'oral
sur les soins palliatifs on l'a écrit
et nous trois je crois nous l'avons
appelé il peut y avoir tous les plans
financiers ils sont utiles
mais c'est pas uniquement les plans
financiers annoncés par un ministre qui
régleront ce problème de soins
d'accompagnement il faut y compris dans
la communauté médicale une petite
révolution
pour que ces soins d'accompagnement
figurent dans le processus de soins
d'impatient lorsque il y a un diagnostic
sur tel ou telle maladie c'est ça qu'il
faut faire quoi pourquoi il y a pas
d'équipe de recherche à une cerne
pourquoi il y a pas de pluph sur ces
sujets pourquoi
ces soins ne figurent pas au sein de au
sein de l'hôpital mais parfois ailleurs
alors
sur ces sujets il faut toujours nuancer
moi j'ai vu des des cas à Toulouse par
exemple en soins de cancérologie ou
les soins d'accompagnement des soins
palliatifs sont fixés dès le début du
traitement et non pas comme dans la
plupart des cas des soins qui des soins
qui interviennent quelques jours c'est
pour ça que mon palliatifs
donc voilà alors ça nécessite pas une
noix ça mais il faut véritablement que
s'il législateur décide d'aborder à
nouveau sujet de point de vue
réglementaire
[Musique]
et à travers des actes très concrètement
que sur l'Agence nationale de la
recherche la NR il y a des programmes
fléchés sur sur ces soins
d'accompagnement d'autres pays le font
qu'il y ait au niveau de la Conférence
des Présidents d'Universités des
instructions faites pour nommer des
paysph dans un certain nombre de
structures c'est ça les actes alors
concernant l'aide active à mourir je
crois qu'on a été très clair d'une part
on a dit s'il législateur décide et
comme la rappeler Régis on envisage deux
cas
c'est l'assistance
au suicide et là nous mettons
très clairement
le cadre dans lequel on doit pas sortir
c'est à dire la recherche du
consentement à travers une autonomie
exprimée par la personne et ça je crois
qu'on exprime très clairement mais on a
voulu c'est pour ça qu'on a été jusqu'au
bout
qu'une personne autonome
psychologiquement qui fait cette demande
mais qu'il physiquement n'a pas la
possibilité de faire l'acte on a voulu
aborder ce sujet en abordant ce sujet
on aborde le tanalie et là
le groupe de travail et du comité
plénier n'a pas voulu trancher sur ce
sujet il a laissé de législateur en
disant il y a deux possibilités la
possibilité la solution actuelle c'est à
dire qu'à un moment dans des conditions
particulières le médecin prend la
responsabilité sous le contrôle d'un
juge
ou la deuxième solution c'est de lever
cette interdite de donner la mort et
aborder le sujet d'euthanasie c'est pas
trahir une délibération pas de sous le
contrôle du président que
large majorité que nous avons eu pour
cet avis au sein de cette large majorité
les avis étaient très partagés sur ce
sujet précis on n'est pas à là pour nous
rédiger un projet ou une proposition de
loi c'est là pour mettre des sujets des
sujets sur la table plus complètement
possible
peut-être un complément de réponse
enfin si on dispose de plusieurs jours
là pour débattre on engage le débat sur
la question de l'autonomie et de la
dignité si vous voulez parce que ce sont
des sujets mais vous avez raison dans ce
que vous pointez monsieur le sénateur
c'est sûr que avoir une vision assez
absolutiste de l'autonomie n'est pas
adaptée
[Musique]
plus on est malade
moi on se connaît plus on se surprend
plus il est difficile d'exercer son
autonomie et plus on a besoin pour
exercer son autonomie d'autrui ce qui
peut paraître un paradoxe et c'est en
particulier comme cela qu'on peut
définir la relation de confiance qu'on
peut avoir avec des des malades
c'est-à-dire qu'on a besoin de cette
dualité pour que la personne chemine etc
vous disiez que il y a beaucoup de
demandes qui changent alors là on a
maintenant
effectivement des travaux qui avaient
été publiés
par la situationnale des études
démographiques qui ont fait l'objet
maintenant de travaux plus qualitatifs
qui montrent que plus on s'approche de
la fin de son existence plus souvent on
change d'avis donc c'est difficile de
s'arrêter sur un navire à un moment un
autre mais ce qui serait grave également
ça serait de nier l'existence d'une
autonomie à la personne au seul motif
qu'elle est gravement malade je pense
réellement qu'on ne peut pas nier le
fait que certaines personnes et
particulièrement dans ce champ que nous
avons dont nous avons parlé qui n'est
pas celui qui était couvert par le qui
est couvert par la loi léonétique laisse
de 2016
nous avons des personnes qui cheminent
pendant des semaines et des mois
qui dont la demande peut être considérée
comme l'expression de leur volonté parce
que cette demande est élaborée qu'elle
est discutée qu'elle a effectivement
quel est le fruit d'une cheminement on
ne peut pas le nier parce que je pense
qu'il y aurait quelque chose
d'irrespectueux d'indigne à penser que
au seul motif que la personne est à la
fin de son existence elle ne peut plus
avoir d'autonomie au qu'on ne peut plus
lui conférer une autonomie c'est très
compliqué ça veut dire qu'il faut un
travail à la classe insistait sur la
notion d'accompagnement on le dit dans
cet avis on l'a dit dans d'autres avis
ce qui ressort de nos réflexions c'est
que tout ce travail d'accompagnement ce
travail d'écoute ce travail d'aide au
cheminement c'est un travail pour les
soignants qui doit être valorisé il ne
l'est pas suffisamment aujourd'hui il ne
l'est pas on valorise avec les
dispositifs en cours comme la
tarification l'activité on valorise
beaucoup plus l'acte technique mais
l'acte relationnel l'acte humain dans
son expression
profonde n'est pas suffisamment
valorisée et je pense que il y aurait un
risque à ne pas c'est ce que nous disons
dans cet avis nous l'avons dit
probablement pas suffisamment clairement
mais il y aurait un risque à se tourner
que vers cette question de l'évolution
du droit sans se tourner vers cette
question de la nécessité de développer
une vraie
culture de l'accompagnement qu'on
appelle une culture palliative on peut
changer les mots mais c'est le sens qui
compte de mon point de vue quant à la
question de la et de mon point de vue
la question n'est donc la question
prioritaire ne demande point de vue pas
celle de l'évolution du droit mais celle
de l'orientation des politiques dans le
domaine de la santé
considérons nous
que dans notre pays
l'accompagnement des personnes en
situation de vulnérabilité
indépendamment soit un palliatif
vieillissement je m'excusais ce mais je
parle bien de personnes en situation de
vulnérabilité est-ce que nous
considérons que dans notre pays nous
avons un devoir de de solidarité et donc
d'accompagnement de ces personnes si oui
à ce moment-là nous pouvons bien entendu
analyser des réalités qui comme nous
l'avons dit existent quoi qu'on
on veut le dire donc c'est pour moi
extrêmement important que nous
réfléchissions au-delà de la question
stricto-sensive de la famille sur
l'accompagnement des personnes en
situation de vulnérabilité je crois
d'ailleurs que le débat public qui doit
être un prisme au travers duquel on voit
notre rapport à la question de la
vulnérabilité à la question de la
solidarité je fais partie de ceux qui
pensent que nous
[Musique]
nous avons
nous faisons société parce que nous
faisons solidarité c'est la raison
d'être la solidarité vis-à-vis des
personnes en situation de vulnérabilité
de ce qui fait le ciment de la société
évidemment vous voyez où est mon
orientation mon souhait
pour terminer à l'un sur cette question
de la de la terminologie et de la
dignité je préfère parler de dignité
comme le faisait Robert Badinter si je
peux me référer à lui pour les personnes
qui sont en vie quelle que soit les
personnes et quel que soit leur vie quel
que soit leur elles sont dignes il y a
une forme ontologique à la au sens de la
dignité je leur rapproche plus cette
question de la dignité à la question de
la vie la question de la mort ou du
mourir ça m'apparaît un débat sans fin
si on veut ressortir ou exhumer cette
question de la de la terminologie mourir
dans la dignité entre guillemets je
préférerais qu'on réfléchisse à vivre
dans notre dignité
on n'a pas retenu dans notre avis c'est
clair
encore une alors encore quelque chose
qui demandera 3 jours de la liberté
c'est encore autre chose que l'autonomie
oui oui oui j'avais raison on emploie au
mot que nous avons utilisé l'autonomie
en la en la en la nuit ensemble comme je
viens d'essayer de le faire et la
solidarité ça nous a paraissait plus
important que d'employer les mots de
dignité de liberté qui sont des
mots-valises et qu'on peut utiliser dans
un sens ou dans l'autre
[Musique]
d'abord un sachet que le
CCNE dans son ensemble se rend compte de
l'extrême complicité de complexité de ce
sujet
il se veut comme une boussole cet avis
se veut comme une boussole pour
comme un processus de démarrage d'une
grande discussion
tout ce qu'on écrit sur ce sujet la main
tremble la Matran parce qu'on touche à
quelque chose de d'extrêmement
fondamental vous en êtes tous conscience
à l'inverse d'autres pays autour de nous
de civilisation de culture certes
différentes mais parfois assez proche
ont su doucement évoluer ou sont en
train d'évoluer donc il est aussi assez
logique que la question se pose en
France
répondre à la question le CCNE avait un
avis différent il y a 7 ou 8 ans
avait un avis d'abord peut-être pas si
différent parce que j'ai en tête et vous
étiez membre du CCNE à cette période
madame la sénatrice dans la vie 129 où
nous avions juste après
juste après
les états généraux de la bioéthique ou
d'avion est déjà évoqué certaines
situations très particulières qui
pouvait exister
et puis je dirais même que j'irai plus
loin c'est-à-dire que est-ce que le CCNE
est là pour tenir quoi qu'il en coûte un
certain nombre de valeurs qui est le
même se contredisent on l'a bien vu
entre autonomie
liberté
sans se très global de la réponse
sociétale
ou est-ce qu'il est là aussi pour tenir
compte des évolutions qui existent dans
notre société
un CCNE qui n'évoluerait pas je dirais
sur un certain nombre de questions alors
même que les questions sont en train de
se poser de façon différente
serait bien sûr serait toujours là mais
somme toute pourquoi faire
et très clairement ça a été indiqué ce
qui a évolué et vous en avez conscience
enfin moi je suis un vieux médecin
il y a j'ai connu l'évolution des soins
palliatifs en France on est toujours en
train de pleurer tous mais ça a
énormément évolué énormément évolué vous
rendez pas compte cette question était
et sur la table il y a eu d'énormes
progrès de fait à la fois chez pas
suffisamment il faut qu'on continue
d'évoluer mais donc un ça évolué et deux
la médecine et Régis la très bien
rappelée nous met maintenant dans des
conditions dans certaines conditions
très particulières quand vous êtes en
cinquième sixième ligne de
chimiothérapie pour une femme avec un
cancer de l'ovaire qui est en stade 4
où on peut s'interroger sur remettre
encore une sixième ligne et soit
est-ce que la médecine dans une certaine
mesure ne conduit pas dans certaines
circonstances à des situations très
complexes en cancérologie c'est en train
également de se produire on a eu un
progrès extraordinaire avec les
minothérapies vous le savez à côté de à
côté des chimiots et inversement est en
train de transformer maintenant avec une
série de succès mais aussi de
d'évolution avec une série de patients
qui rentrent dans des états de
chronicité et là aussi de troisième
quatrième cinquième ligne
et ça n'existait pas il y a 10 ans
donc notre monde est en train de changer
est-ce que le CCNE doit par principe ne
pas évoluer ou est-ce qu'il doit tenir
compte aussi de l'évolution à la fois de
la science et de l'évolution sociétale
alors la deuxième question auquel on a
pas répondu je vais y répondre et tu as
posé une très bonne question c'est les
soignants
c'est alors je l'ai vécu moi j'ai vécu
des choses
l'évolution qui s'est passé au moment du
du sida dans une période extrêmement
difficile des années noires des années
90 94 on a été amené à prendre un
certain nombre de décisions il n'y avait
pas de loi et mes jeunes agrégés m'ont
toujours dit vous avez pris à ce
moment-là un certain nombre de décisions
votre âme est conscience avec les
équipes soignantes en ayant d'ailleurs
interrogé le Conseil de l'Ordre qui ne
répondait pas
et sur
et nous on ne peut pas les prendre parce
que vous avez construit ensuite des lois
et maintenant la jeune médecine
se vit avec les lois c'est comme ça
c'est ce qu'on peut le regretter mais
c'est ou ne pas le regretter mais ils
vivent avec les lois et ils ont ça en
tête alors la question posée n'était pas
celle-là c'était de dire est-ce qu'il
n'y a pas une contradiction à demander
aux médecins de sauver de la mort et de
donner la mort bien sûr qu'il y a une
contradiction majeure et tu le sais
parfaitement
c'est pour il s'est bien pour ça que
dans les modèles entre guillemets et il
faut bien distinguer et régissent la
très bien fait de distinguer ce qui est
l'aide l'assistance entre guillemets par
rapport à l'euthanasie et si je regarde
le modèle Suisse par exemple il y a bien
une décision médicale collégiale de
pouvoir fournir le médicament et le
médicament est fourni par une par une
association et vous le savez qui qui
fait qui fait une grande partie de du
job en Suisse là dessus bon mais ça
existe également en Oregon c'est les
modèles sont un peu différents en
Belgique et et dans d'autres pays et
Hollande en particulier
alors il y aura sûrement à devoir de
réserve une Conseil de l'Ordre là déjà
là déjà souligné et bien sûr c'est cette
question va se poser la vraie question
qui a derrière c'est est-ce que compte
tenu du changement que 90 % des décès
ont lieu maintenant dans un milieu
médicalisé est-ce qu'on reste finalement
avec
l'ensemble des décisions qui restent
entre les mains des médecins
ou est-ce que on laisse une partie de
ces décisions entre les mains de
l'individu et que si les médecins en
effet pour des raisons diverses ne
souhaitent pas participer à cette
décision ils ont bien sûr un devoir de
réserve qui est parfaitement jouable et
qu'on a et qu'on a déjà exercé dans
d'autres conditions vous le savez
c'est un problème essentiel
l'Espagne il y a trois ans a construit
une loi
qui est passée qui est passé qui a été
voté dans un peu rapide sans écouter son
prendre le temps de discuter avec les
équipes soignantes et cette loi est
bloquée elle n'est pas appliquée parce
que les équipes soignantes ne souhaitent
pas une veulent pas l'appliquer donc en
effet un des très gros risques
d'évolution possible c'est si on ne
prend pas le temps de discuter avec
l'ensemble des équipes soignantes et
c'est pour ça que l'enquête du Conseil
de l'Ordre est intéressante
j'entends par équipe soignante non
seulement les médecins mais les
aides-soignantes
et vous verrez vous écouterez
probablement l'ensemble et vous verrez
qu'il y a parfois de grosses nuances et
que la fin de vie appartient aussi bien
aux aides-soignantes comme médecin et
deuxièmement que les médecins ne sont
pas seulement les médecins des soins
palliatifs et qui a également tout un
corps médical les cancérologues etc qui
ont accompagné leur patience et dont il
va falloir également écouter la vie sur
le fond
je me permets de renforcer juste une
seconde ce que vient de dire
Jean-François de fraissy
l'implication du professionnel de santé
dans l'assistance officide n'a rien à
voir avec l'implication du profil de
santé dans l'euthanasie je l'ai dit mais
et c'est fondamental à mon avis de faire
cette différence et c'est pourquoi nous
l'avions fait remarquer
dans une des discussions avec la
proposition de loi portée par Monsieur
Falorni cette distinction n'était pas
suffisamment faite et qu'il faut à mon
avis
c'est trop important pour que nous
n'ayons cette réalité fondamentale
fondamentalement différente
merci beaucoup alors Olivier Hainaut
ensuite Daniel chasseur victoire Olivier
nous merci madame la Présidente merci
pour vos exposer tout en nuances et
évidemment et que la part de doute qu'on
doit toujours avoir sur ces sujets
lorsqu'on a
auditionné lors du projet de loi de
bioéthique vous aviez monsieur le
professeur delphréty dit cette phrase
terrible j'avais trouvé ça terrible mais
ou combien juste on meurt mal dans notre
pays moi j'avoue que ça m'avait beaucoup
marqué alors il y avait il y a la
question des EHPAD mais il me semble pas
seulement
alors c'est empirique ce que je vais
exprimer là mais je viens aussi d'être
un peu
interpellé par le chiffre de 90% des
personnes meurent à l'hôpital
90% des personnes meurent à l'hôpital et
puis vous avez eu cette phrase notre
mort nous appartient-elle ou
appartient-elle à la société qu'il a
délégué au médecin
j'ai un peu le sentiment que le principe
d'autonomie
monte dans notre société aux dépens du
principe de solidarité mais au fond il y
a pas de temps il y a pas que sur ce
sujet forme de
d'invédusalisme qui correspond aussi à
une forme d'armericanisation de la
société de cette culture américaine qui
nous embête nous envahit peu au prout
tout de même bon
et
souvent j'entends les gens qui sont qui
se rapprochent de la mort dire moi je
voudrais mourir chez moi
mais c'est un truc qu'on entend tout le
temps
or de fait c'est loin d'être le cas et
je pense que ça participe à la
l'accroissement de l'angoisse de la mort
et je pense que ça participe aussi à la
montée du principe d'autonomie et donc
ma question mais de manière totalement
empirique sans avoir de
solutions est-ce que c'est inéluctable
cette question de 90% de personnes qui
meurent à l'hôpital est-ce qu'il y a pas
un chemin
pour à la fois mourir dans la dignité et
mourir chez soi voilà la question qui
que je me pose sous est très fréquemment
de manière assez empirique je vous
remercie
Daniel Chassain merci madame la
Présidente merci sur le professeur et
merci messieurs pour toutes ces
explications qui ont été données et vous
avez effectivement indiqué qu'il y a des
situations difficiles
tous les âges
les cancers les maladies
neurones
des situations rares est-ce que la loi
suffit vous avez répondu que
effectivement il y a des situations où
elle est peut-être pas suffisante mais
je reprendrai à ce qu'elle dit Olivier
nous aussi
il y a peu de personnes qui meurent à
domicile c'est parce que il y a pas
suffisamment d'accompagnement
d'accompagnement si vous voulez de la
famille
d'accompagnement aussi du médecin ou de
ou de l'infirmière qui aura des
difficultés
lorsque dans les derniers jours
elle sera elle n'aura pas forcément
toutes les trois pas réglé ni le médecin
toutes les situations
puisque lorsqu'on est à l'hôpital on est
quand même on peut avoir des drogues
plus beaucoup plus facilement qu'à
domicile mais tout tout est le problème
d'accompagnement et je pense que c'est
pas suffisant parce que on sait que même
si l'immunothérapie a fait beaucoup de
progrès et heureusement il y a des
guérissons même lorsque on est dans des
stades comme vous l'avez dit très avancé
mais on sait quand même que dans
certains cas malgré les soins on sait
que progressivement ça va s'aggraver et
on n'aura pas de guérison et on va
arriver au moment où on va être en
difficulté et je pense que c'est là où
on n'a pas suffisamment d'accompagnement
qui est qui est qui est qui a commencé
depuis déjà plusieurs mois et c'est
simplement la fin parce que lorsque on
accompagne les gens ils auront pas cet
avis si vous voulez de vouloir mourir ou
si on les accompagne d'abord en
psychologiquement mais aussi
au niveau de l'aide à au soulagement
donc moi je pense que c'est là le gros
problème parce que la loi léonique les a
fait énormément de progrès lorsqu'elle
est appliquée dans des départements
notamment des départements ruraux comme
la Corrèze où il y a des soins
palliatifs qui se déplacent dans les
EHPAD même à domicile et bien notamment
dans les EHPAD on a quand même beaucoup
moins de difficultés et les familles
apprécient bien sûr beaucoup cet
accompagnement mais il
sait s'accompagnement des soins
palliatifs et sur les derniers jours
lorsqu'on leur faire appel ou les les
dernières semaines je pense qu'il
faudrait qu'il soit pris en amont mais
est-ce qu'on doit changer une loi ou
simplement l'adapter parce que en fait
dans certains départements ça n'existe
pas est-ce qu'il faut pas renforcer
cette loi dans le sens de
l'accompagnement c'est à dire renforcer
en fait les soins palliatifs et intégrés
comme vous l'avez dit les autres
médecins qui interviennent en amont
notamment l'équipe avec l'infirmière et
l'aide-soignante
victoire
jasmin oui merci madame la Présidente
merci
aux différentes intervenants
j'apprécie le débat le débat que nous
avons ici un débat où on parle quand
même de solidarité de dignité et on
parle également de souffrance des
soignants pourtant je n'arrive toujours
pas à comprendre comment a-t-on pu
banaliser l'administration du Rivotril
il y a quelques mois on n'a pas tenu
compte de tout cela voilà merci
merci
moi je vais avant de passer la question
cette notion de mourir dans la dignité
moi m'a toujours un peu je l'ai dit à
chaque fois qu'il y avait les débats
se dire on a tous dans nos entourage
connu des gens qui étaient en fin de vie
avec parfois en effet une fin de vie qui
n'était pas celle qu'il souhaitait et
qu'on souhaitait pour eux mais jamais
aucun moment on a jugé qu'ils étaient
indignes la dignité elle est jusqu'au
dernier souffle et le nom de cette
association en train de mourir d'un
dignité moi me perturbe complètement un
côté que que je trouve un peu choquant
même donc ça c'est ça bon ce qui s'est
passé en Belgique avec cette jeune femme
qui
était des gros en grande souffrance
après après des attentats quel est votre
regard en effet sur cette situation et
puis il veut des articles bon peut-être
comme tous les articles de journaux du
week-end peut-être un peu réducteur mais
qui disait que des mutuelles se
positionnaient aussi et ça ça incite un
peu et ça revient la question posée
Corinne Humbert est-ce que finalement
c'est pas aussi une solution pour
développer des soins palliatifs
alors c'est peut-être un peu loin
derrière un côté économique derrière je
n'irai pas jusque là parce que ce serait
sûrement caricatural mais néanmoins ça
fait ça fait poser beaucoup de questions
sur la question alors sur la question on
meurt mal en France on en a beaucoup
discuté avec
Jean-François je pense que nous nous
reprendrions pas vraiment cette
expression aujourd'hui parce que si on
la retourne il faut qu'on il faut qu'on
se dise qu'est-ce que ce serait bien
mourir et nous ne savons pas répondre à
cette question je ne crois même qu'il
serait un peu hasardeuse d'imaginer que
l'on puisse mourir heureux enfin
excusez-moi mais je pense que c'est une
épreuve ça fait partie de ces épreuves
de la vie c'est pas la seule d'ailleurs
qui ne peut pas être autrement que
douloureuse quand on disait cela on le
disait pour dire en réalité souligner
l'insuffisance des moyens dont on a
parlé ici vous évoquiez les uns et les
autres la question du domicile et en
particulier
parce que on devrait aussi distinguer
contenu de ce qu'on vient de dire aussi
du fait que la fin de vie le temps de la
fin de vie est en train d'augmenter de
façon considérable on devrait distinguer
la question du lieu de la fin de vie
d'éventuellement du lieu du mourir et
c'est bien du lieu de la fin de vie
qu'il s'agit quand les gens disent
autant pas finir à l'hôpital parce que
ça pourrait être une longue période
et quoi qu'il en soit si le domicile est
plébiscité dans dans tous les travaux
qui ont été publiés sur ce point de vue
là on voit bien qu'il est quand même
difficile de permettre la fin de
l'existence au domicile c'est difficile
parce que notre société totalement
changé en 50 ans les la possibilité de
garder à domicile quelqu'un qui pendant
des semaines des mois et dépendant
douloureux etc il y a plus de familles
multigénération fait d'habitat
multigénérationnel disons pratiquement
disparu c'est déjà une explication puis
une explication extrêmement importante
il se trouve que j'ai dirigé
l'Observatoire national de la fin de vie
nous avions beaucoup travaillé sur cette
question il y a des professionnels qui
en France par rapport à d'autres pays ne
sont pas assez valorisés Jean-François
parler des aides-soignantes mais je
parlerai des aides à domicile voilà une
profession
insuffisamment formée insuffisant
rémunéré insuffisant reconnu qu'on
envoie
littéralement et donc nous ne trouvons
pas assez aujourd'hui d'aide à domicile
c'est probablement le nœud gordien du
maintien à domicile enfin une autre un
autre aspect un autre nœud gordien du
maintien de missile c'est pas être seul
et on cite quelques rapports dans notre
avis qui montre leur rapport de la des
petits frères des Pauvres en particulier
qui montre combien la solitude augmente
à la fin de la vie dans ce pays de façon
très très inquiétante et mourir seule
ça rend les choses impossibles vous
voyez bien quelque part quand vous posez
cette question qui est tout à fait juste
de mon point de vue les réponses à
apporter dépassent le strict cadre de
mon point de vue de la fin de la vie
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on veut en termes de
politique d'accompagnement des
vulnérabilité parce que je la même
question se pose pour des personnes dont
on ne dit pas qu'elles sont en fin de
vie mais dont on pourrait penser
qu'elles sont à la fin de leur existence
ce sont certaines personnes âgées nous
avions commis un autre avis la vie 128
il y a quelques années qui montraient
que lorsqu'on contraint des personnes à
aller là où elle ne souhaite pas aller
dans certains EHPAD il s'agit pas d'une
critique des EHPAD il s'agit de d'une
critique de l'absence l'insuffisance des
alternatives et bien elle ne peuvent pas
bien finir leur existence certaines
choisissent le suicide c'est aussi pour
ça que nous sommes très vigilants à
faire coexister notre réflexion sur
l'évolution du droit à l'obligation
d'avoir des politiques d'accompagnement
des vulnérabilités
et puis justement par rapport à votre
question sur le sur le rivotril
[Musique]
il y a eu vous vous rappelez peut-être
que pendant la première vague je parle
sous ton contrôle Jean-François il y a
eu face à une pénurie du midazolam qui
est un médicament que nous utilisons
pour la sédation profonde et continue
jusqu'au décès face à une pénurie qui
était liée à une utilisation massive
dans les services de réanimation il y a
eu une insuffisance de disponibilité de
ce médicament mis d'azolam et il y avait
en même temps à ce moment là je parle de
la première vague des situations de fin
de vie à domicile ou dans les EHPAD qui
nécessitaient que nous ayons parfois
recours à un médicament pour endormir
les personnes à défaut du milieu
d'azolam il y a eu une autorisation
temporaire d'accès aux
rivotril qui est un autre médicament
mais ça n'est pas le médicament le plus
adapté puisqu' au contraire à la Haute
Autorité de Santé avait démontré que ce
n'était pas celui-ci qu'il fallait
auquel il fallait mais un autre mais
maintenant que cette pénurie n'a plus
lieu il n'y a plus d'utilisation et
d'indications à utiliser du Rivotril
juste un mot
au-delà de la vie
je pense que ce soit législateur que ce
soit
l'exécutif ou que ça soit des organismes
qui réfléchissent sur ce sujet
c'est vrai j'en prends soin d'être aussi
à raison
que de progrès franchit sur ses soins
dit palliatifs
mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui il y a une
petite révolution encore à faire sur ce
sujet que j'appelle soin
d'accompagnement
si on prend pas un certain nombre de
mesures
on tournera un rond pendant longtemps je
prends un seul exemple la T2A
ça a été un progrès à l'hôpital
l'introduire ce mode de financement par
rapport aux dotations de fonctionnement
mais je suis convaincu que vous-même
vous l'exécutif auront à se poser la
question est-ce que c'est soit
l'accompagnement doivent pas sortir de
tes deux ans
je pense que ce sujet il est devant nous
et je pense que
prendre une telle décision
aurait beaucoup plus d'efficacité que
tous ces plantes sont un palliatifs
quand quel que soit les gouvernements on
a mis donc c'est un sujet qui est devant
nous sur la mobilité parce que c'est ça
cette question de pas mourir pas vouloir
mourir à l'hôpital
il y a des choses concrètes vous
connaissez par cœur les EHPAD
87 ans et demi
le vendredi à 18h
il n'y a plus d'infirmière le médecin
coordinateur n'est plus là donc il y a
de moins de problèmes aux urgences
tous les chiffres tous les connaît tous
les connaissances donc c'est sur ces
sujets là on doit peser puis un dernier
sujet
je crois que
on n'a pas fini de réfléchir à cette
notion par rapport à ce que disent
Jean-François et régis par rapport aux
progrès scientifiques et c'est un sujet
peut-être qu'on aura abordé nous au CCNE
sur cette notion d'obstination
déraisonnable
est-ce qu'on a été au bout de la
réflexion je pense que c'est sûrement un
sujet pour nous c'est CNE mais pour vous
législateur sur lequel il faudra il
faudra à nouveau réfléchir
oui madame la Présidente moi je voudrais
vous remercier messieurs en tout cas de
ce rapport qui est riche et
particulièrement instructif sur sur un
sujet compliqué il est vrai j'ai une
question et une remarque ma question
pensez-vous que que nous avons les
moyens et je pense qu'il faut c'est un
passage obligé pour moi je voudrais
avoir votre avis de pouvoir évaluer
d'être en capacité d'évaluer cette loi
de 2016 dans toutes ses composantes
avant peut-être d'élucubrer et d'aller
plus loin sur ce sujet je voudrais avoir
votre avis là dessus en tout cas moi
j'en suis personnellement convaincu et
puis je voudrais insister sur cette idée
que vous avez développé mais à mon avis
pas suffisamment que la finitude n'est
pas un échec et je crois qu'on est
encore malheureusement
trop enclin à penser aujourd'hui dans
notre société mais pas qu'en France que
la finitude est un échec je vous
remercie
sur l'évaluation de la loi classique bon
on touche là du doigt
le fait que nous avons
culture assez faible en France de
l'évaluation des politiques publiques
c'est
à la fois bon fait assez peu de choses
disons-le que dans le domaine de la
santé qu'on connaît le mieux mais
ailleurs aussi me semble-t-il
c'est en plus fait souvent par des
cabinets d'audits extérieure
il y a assez peu de demandes à
l'université qui où il y aurait d'une
expertise qui pourrait qui pourrait
aider entre guillemets à une forme
d'évaluation des politiques publiques
et il n'y a pas de à ce jour en tout cas
nous l'avions demandé
dès le début de de la de la réflexion du
groupe de travail des juin 2021
mais il n'y a pas à ce jour de bonne
évaluation claire au niveau du ministère
de la Santé en tout cas nous ne l'avons
pas
de de cette de la locationnetti alors je
pense qu'il y a une demande qui a été
faite
je crois avec une enquête Cour des
comptes menée par l'Assemblée nationale
et qui est prévu pour avoir une première
forme d'évaluation au mois de mars
si s'il y avait d'ailleurs au passage
s'il y avait pour une loi de s'il avait
une évolution dans la loi et peut-être
qu'il n'y aura pas d'évolution dans la
loi il faut être clair il serait
fondamental à nos yeux que les
parlementaires et les sénateurs au sens
très large du terme puisse demander dans
le cadre même de la loi qui est une
évaluation de la nouvelle loi dans un
temps donné c'est quelque chose je sais
pas si c'est faisable je ne connais rien
dans dans les pratiques parlementaires
mais mais ça serait ça devrait être
vraiment sur des grandes des grandes
décisions de politique publique c'est ça
ça paraît fondamental
donc la réponse oui on l'aura dans un
délai de je dirais au printemps de 2000
2023 c'est à dire un moment donné où la
convention citoyenne sera en train de se
terminer et où il y aura donc
probablement un ensemble de données qui
vont qui vont être qui vont être qui
vont construire un peu le mécano de nos
connaissances
la Cour des comptes c'est sur les soins
palliatifs sur les soins palliatifs mais
il y a également probablement une j'ai
compris qu'il y aurait une demande
probablement passant par l'IGAS de
l'Assemblée nationale sur évaluation de
la loi classique
je te laisse répondre pour la suite
c'est quoi notre
c'était la fin de vie n'est pas
n'est pas n'est pas forcément une
enfin de considérons pas la finitude
comme un échec
oui mais vous avez raison quand vous
parlez de cette
assimilation littéralement qui est faite
par les médecins en particulier de la
fin de la vie et de la mort comme étant
leur échec il y a quelque chose qui
biaise totalement la possibilité au
contraire d'être dans un cheminement
mais ça rejoint aussi toute une
discussion sur
la nécessité de penser ce qu'on appelle
par ailleurs des niveaux de soins je
disais tout à l'heure ça n'est pas parce
que l'on sait faire que l'on doit faire
on devrait interroger face à la
complexité et de façon très
interdisciplinaire le sens même de ce
que soignait veut dire et de ce que
traiter veut dire et parfois et c'est
probablement la décision qui aujourd'hui
la plus difficile pour un médecin décidé
de ne pas faire avec quelque chose qui
peut être plus bénéfique que décidé de
faire nous en avons beaucoup parlé de
cette question que vous posez là parce
que dans un autre avis en préparation
on voit bien que cette question
interroge
le sens même de ce que soignait veut
dire et de ce que vivre veut dire et que
en miroir de cette question qui n'est
pas abordée et bien il y a la souffrance
des soignants
quand vous ne savez plus pourquoi vous
vous travaillez quand vous vous posez
plus les bonnes questions vous avez de
mon point de vue une des explications ça
serait assez réducteur de le réduire à
cela mais c'est une explication
importante de la souffrance actuelle
dans le monde de du soin et de la santé
et c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
important de mon point de vue de
développer
probablement dans un autre avis nous
nous en reparlerons mais de développer
non pas simplement une culture du soin
palliatif mais une culture de la
réflexion éthique
hésiter ne pas être sûr de soi
travailler collectivement
interroger les limites du savoir les
limites de la ville les limites du sens
et bien si ceci peut s'apprendre
mais ceci s'éprouve de façon il faut
valoriser le travail en équipe il faut
valoriser le temps nous faisons le
constat dans d'autres travaux que nous
menons que parfois les temps des
personnes malades et des familles ne
croisent plus les temps des soignants
c'est quelque chose qui est dramatique
ça de mon point de vue
pour être peut-être plus clair juste
deux minutes
donc pour être clair parce que je viens
de dire peut-être dans un prochain
je mets clairement vous expliquer nous
nous sortirons un prochain avis
probablement d'ici la fin octobre sur en
géolétique et quelle valeur pour la
reconstruction du système de soins et
qui pose vraiment au cœur de cet avis la
notion que la notion du temps et la
notion du temps du soignant et la notion
du temps du soignant pour les familles
et la notion du temps pour les patients
est un élément clé de cette
reconstruction et que c'est une valeur
fondamentale qui a été qui a été
beaucoup négligée au cours des dernières
années donc voilà c'était pour clarifier
ce que tu veux me dire voilà donc ce qui
veut dire que nous serons prochainement
une nouvelle audition
pour pour nous présentiez cet avis car
en effet majeur merci beaucoup pour
cette présentation et à bientôt à
bientôt merci beaucoup donc rendez-vous
demain matin 9h30 en commission